what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we are shooting this
right after we have shot our cyberpunk
2077 yeah that's what you're checking
out that reaction we're putting this one
up in the morning though but as
mentioned in that video we just got back
from Dan and Alyssa's wedding so go show
them some love wish them a
congratulations by subscribing to their
channels and streaming their wedding on
Twitch yes after you know seven-hour
road trip or hopping on to this one now
Star Wars Jedi fall in an order official
gameplay demo let's get into the show
[Music]
it's nice to watch some YouTube videos
after a weekend away
[Music]
oh cool so this is how a Jedi would do a
hardcore okay
[Music]
oh yes your blame your supper finery
last day Saul Guerrero yeah bear while
with tree said it would be good
who funds happened to a powerful
compound therefore so what a girl
returned production
[Music]
[Music]
it looks like Cameron Monaghan
he is Cameron is he oh it looks exactly
like you I didn't know that yeah I think
his name is calc Estes in this game cool
young padawan the Jedi
Jon could you turn me to remind you to
be professional dope
this looks so cool oh I get to do a
whole lot with the force in this game
huh
[Music]
[Music]
awesome so much horsepower
[Music]
[Music]
like is your Rogers hi boomerang light
save damn damn
back here the first Star Wars game I
ever beat was the Force Unleashed so so
excited
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I will make you hurt
oh it was a sidekick that took him down
[Music]
the portrait Bertie trained there so
long to be the Jedi
let's go out in two minutes hey made a
lot farther than any of the troopers
[Music]
like men
what if you can use that guy like like
metal gear
music Jews
[Music]
whoa what do clean throwers like
bullet-time horsemen yeah
[Music]
how that parcours like justified in the
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
of course Wow
[Music]
[Music]
we're busy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
it's like a giant spider
[Music]
I hope the joy doesn't die in the game I
know I would be so sad are you like
poisoned or something
whoa that one was why shock is oh my god
that thing bit your neck it looked I
think this is kiss she care what I'm
doing let's go comment below
love the weird motion blur
[Music]
forces stopping things in motion
I love how this is such a way cool like
so many games have sadness pretty
[ __ ] lot of games that it's like my
favorite those to rise early why would
you do any other moves doing a kylo Ren
right there that is so bad that was
great
[Music]
Robin I said why would you do any other
move they show us another better to an
ambush
they got that oh yes
[Music]
love now love the music in this yes
chop his head off
[Music]
come on man you got whoa look at that
hey it's a great thing about lightsabers
too is like they got to cauterize all
those wounds so there's a great reason
to have no blood
cars
[Music]
- quiet
[Music]
No
that a k2s out
[Music]
looks great
that looks very cool it looks great I
love it loved it Xbox one
absolutely and PlayStation and hey if
it's on Nintendo as well which this game
probably won't be but yeah you know all
the games are good game that looks
awesome
and I was a little late to playing the
Star Wars games and the first one I ever
like full-on completed but star wars the
force unleashed I got that on the Wii
when you're able to make it a lightsaber
so you're swinging and stuff that's so
much fun it reminded me a lot of that
could have been like a part through you
know I don't seem like that but you know
with a lot more options on what you can
do you get such a wide variety of force
powers here which looks so cool to me
all the pulling like you pointed out the
motions like whenever he's stopping
something that's fully in motion whether
that's a person item or laser that's
your favorite moves obviously for us if
you've watched the reaction movie when
they pull them so with a boomerang one
man when they combine that with the
laser mid-air yeah yeah I was like yeah
that's how the force awakens then pushes
them in but that was excellent try to
myself for picking up in those camera
monahan right there yeah I was like huh
looks like the design him after like
aramony I must be a little bit more
famous since since doing his work as
Joker I know they said what was this
alpha game footage so they have some
more effects you know it's a perfect a
little bit more everything looks great
in terms of the world development I
think some of the cinematic cutscenes
could look a little bit better
Sagar Erica look a little better Wookiee
especially very old-school not really
here for judging the cinematic graphics
I'm here to watch the gameplay and the
gameplay itself does look really awesome
I want to see more of the personality of
this charismatic Jedi got Cameron
Monaghan in here he's our main character
he seems like such a really nice guy his
personality harkens back a little bit
more towards like the Luke Skywalker
kind of
not saying he's a Skywalker I'm just
saying his the cadence in the way he
carries himself and the overall like
optimism in the way he kind of maneuvers
around reminded me of him a bit yeah
well I wonder what the overall story of
this game is gonna be because I know
that they hired the guy who did the
story for mafia 3 which is not a
well-beloved game in terms of gameplay
but had a really well-received storyline
a lot of people said was like when their
favorite video game stories of that year
so - for me like coming out of the
movies and stuff and not being the
biggest Star Wars movie fan I almost
feel like I would enjoy the Star Wars
universe even more as a video game
because watching something like this or
the battlefront footage we've watched in
the past the worlds that you get to
really explore in like really enchant me
so much and the creature designs and
everything and they worked with
Lucasfilm on this game to you know come
up with new worlds and new creatures and
stuff really bring it to life more of
the gameplay that I like some of the
fighting does remind me I've been
playing the Spider Man on ps4 which a
lot of people have referenced like to
the Batman Arkham games not exactly but
a little bit of that specially when
you're fighting around a variety of them
towards the end before the Droid showed
up when he's fighting multiples of them
at once it kind of reminded me of that
especially with the camera angles all
that stuff with the climbing you
immediately flash the things like
assassin's creed or uncharted one thing
that always pops in my mind whenever I
play those games is so unrealistic a
human couldn't do this but when you got
a Jedi who's like literally running on
the walls like oh well it's got the
force it has established in the Star
Wars movies Jedi's can usually jump
pretty high themselves you know do a lot
of cool flips while they're doing it so
even though it's it's reminding me of
those other games well it's actually
well more justified here better than
those other ones but this looks great
yeah I'm excited for this game one of
the music - like straight out of the
movies and stuff like that makes me
wonder if they're ripping just
soundtrack elements or if they have
original compositions for these no John
Williams said I'm gonna come back for
this game yeah yeah all the power - yeah
and wonder how Star Wars fans are
responding to this you know the
easiest-going crowd in the world oh yeah
this takes place on the prequels time
that ya know the stakes are high
before Rwanda I can't remember exactly
somewhere episode 1 or 3 somewhere in
that I know is definitely in the prequel
space he seemed
he's like a young Jedi he doesn't he
still could be like what a Padawan right
he is a Padawan yeah and he's one of the
last because this is basically the point
where the Empire is said like okay I
mean Jedi who you know stand against the
Empire we're gonna use lethal force on
them hunt them all down kill them okay
cool so yeah so you're on the run right
everything that this game wanted me to
pick up on while I was watching this so
have you done any research I picked up
on storytelling on the video game here
alright guys well are you excited for
Star Wars Jedi fallen order leave your
comments down in the comment boxes below
I would like to give a patron the day
shout out to a man named Danielle gala
Connor
Daniel my friend we are constantly
talking about video games you are
telling me about how you're enjoying the
ps4 a game I think you got to stop
everything you're doing and put all your
money towards purchasing this Star Wars
video game that does not mean stop
pledging to our patreon if you being
able to afford this game would mean you
have to sacrifice your patreon pledge
don't do it it's not worth it matter of
fact if you want to sell your game
systems and increase your patreon
pledges that's even better and then pick
up more shifts at the pharmacy and then
you know put that into your pledge as
well you know keep it coming men don't
want us down triple your pledge
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell Daniel keep your
pledge as it is if you like this video
hit that like button also make sure to
wish Dan and Elissa congratulations on
their wedding not engagement ended at
the marriage you know on trust that
super engagement along